president Trump's legal team on the
Senate floor right now making the case
against impeachment as you know this
comes as the fight over witnesses
intensifies yet again this time it's
over claims and former National Security
Advisor John Bolton's new book the new
york times reporting that in an
unpublished manuscript bolton alleges
the president trump tied aid to Ukraine
- the investigation into the Biden's the
report fueling a new battle over
testimony among lawmakers and here's the
president denying John Bolton's claims
earlier today I haven't seen a
manuscript but I can tell you nothing
was ever said to Dina let me ask you do
you think this moves the needle on
Republicans voting to call witnesses
it's possible it's possible but I think
there's we've got a ways to go because
before you even get to a vote about
witnesses you have I think another two
maybe even a day or so it depends on how
much time the president's lawyers want
to use so it could but maybe we'll find
out more about all of this before then
even if we do get to witnesses as Jesse
was pointing out just a moment ago you
could get to a point where it's clear if
there's gonna be witnesses and there's
gonna be all the witnesses it's not
going to just be john bolton makhmour
vanie it's going to be like that you
won't get to do the no witnesses like
the house did a couple of things on this
obvious i know john bolton i was a
spokesperson when he was trying to be
appointed well when the president
President Bush had appointed him to the
United Nations and the Democrats blocked
that they called him a liar all sorts of
things remember that and they're not
kind of a liar now I also am I'm for
people writing books but I also have
long to believed that the best way to
write a book if you've had an
opportunity in the privilege to work on
an administration is to do so after a
term is over either when the president
is no longer the president I think books
that had come in the middle of it always
end up being looking like it's for
personal gain even if it isn't
necessarily that way and if they're
always taken the wrong way and they hurt
the very person that gave you the
opportunity to work in the White House
typically because the media will always
try to find a way to see if there's a
way to divide third thing is though
that I predicted this on Friday I said I
would not be surprised if by Sunday
night there's another one of these
little leaks because the Democrats might
realize that they know that the
president is going to be acquitted but
they're gonna figure out a way to make
it very difficult for them as much as
they possibly can and this happens on
Sunday night but here's what I would
also say that that might be wrong but
the White House any White House has to
figure out a way to get much more
coordinated like everybody needs to know
that Oh heads up everybody
John Bolton's manuscript just landed in
the National Security Council's desk
whoo oh it needs to be there to know
about it but they didn't do that
apparently it looks like they didn't do
that and so that means that then they
were looked like they were caught a
little bit flat-footed today I dig and
you know one thing that strikes me is
picking up on what Dana just said about
her accurate prediction that we've had
the left Parnas thing come out we then
had the OMB email about the money being
withheld after the phone call we had the
GAO saying this was illegal now we've
got Bolton and he's naming names it
looks like a drip drip drip where do you
do you know why we're laughing tell me I
mean it's obviously a coordinated stunt
walk wait wait wait in fact Bolton and
his lawyer of sadqa' they didn't review
all the e-book here's why I'm not buying
this bolt and stuff and I've been around
not that long but long enough to know
this is a hatchet job
how many perfectly timed anonymous
cherry-picked revelations have been
leaked perfectly timed to help the
Democrats to the New York Times Jim
Comey
Jim honey are these the same anonymous
sources that said that there was Russia
collusion I mean are these the same
anonymous people in the NSA but even
though they tried to draw up this whole
list so we don't know who leaks it we
know why the timing tells you why this
isn't order to like to nail the
president but the thing I don't
understand is nobody's actually see
right the actual quote could actually
defend it could defend well I mean
here's the deal people are freaking out
on the write about this and I'm going
like it vindicates Trump because he's
telling everybody what Trump really
thought which it was that you
was corrupt and he was on behalf of the
Dems and this is what he's trying to do
but now this is just like another
bombshell
the media has TBD terminal bombshell
disease a bounce it's a bombshell
but it's nothing but the bottom line is
nobody knows what it is well here's what
I think it is because they'd actually
lied about what they say the revelation
is they don't get to page four and so
they tell you the meat of the
conversation that Bolton had with the
president this is a direct quote from
the New York Times okay this is supposed
to be the good stuff he the president
quote preferred sending no assistance to
Ukraine until officials had turned over
all the materials they had about the
Russia investigation that related to mr.
Biden and supporters of mrs. Clinton and
Ukraine so this wasn't about Purisima or
hunter this was about them releasing
information about election interference
and collusion by the Democrats against
the president so that's why this murky
leak is probably from some guy that
maybe saw manuscripts spun it to The
Times and they can't corroborate it
because they don't have it I don't make
make a recommendation on something oh do
you have something that's okay I don't
have I never have those so I I think
that the when you do a book in the
middle of a president even if you were
especially if you had top-secret
clearance you have to get it cleared
from the government so he sends it in
that's the appropriate procedure to do
well they haven't cleared it but the
President of the United States has the
ability to clear it if he wants to so
they could release that chapter or they
could tell john bolton like we're good
with your book like whatever they could
release it and then and try to do that
before this question leads to an amazon
today not a conspiracy that's the bike
conspiracy it has nothing to do with the
impeachment it's the publish yes no I
don't think that's a conspiracy javelin
literary categorically state they had
absolutely absolutely no coordination
with it but I will point this out so if
you think that your author is going to
give away what's in the book you need to
pre-sell that book expletive before he
before he actually testifies potentially
that this is you strike while that iron
as hot and this is the moment and by the
way still last time I looked still not
even number one Kobe Bryant's number one
so this hasn't even juice sales but the
time to trying to sell it ahead of
possible let's just get back to today I
don't think there's any question he tied
President Trump to a quid pro quo and
this is a trump official that's why it's
yep not Purisima none to the